The time is 1205 years in the Sicilian calendar.The
Zemuria Corps, which is a powerful force, comes to
the northwestern part of the region.In the
Northumbria Autonomous Region,
the heroes of the revolution once launched the Northern Ryohei to protect their territory.
Ravi,
a girl born and raised in Northumbria, volunteered
for Ryohei in order to protect the peace of Northumbria.
In the
midst of
all this, the Peremonian Empire, one of the two great powers of the Semurian continent,
has expanded its hegemony
and annexed the neighboring country of Crossbell Autonomous Province, making
it a buffer between the Empire and the Republic.
The Republic was forced to withdraw
That's why
the heroes of the empire appeared
I was born in this place I am what I am
thanks to the heroes Once upon a time
[music]
I had to do something  A
Rabbie subject You will be asked to infiltrate the
empire.I will undertake a mission.Rabbie and three companions will infiltrate the empire to find out the identity of
the main force behind the enemy's shadow,
the hero of the empire, the
Gray Knight.
Isn't it time for you to
turn your eyes away
forever?  A
new revolution is needed
Eternal glory and prosperity The
law is about to become noisy
The annexation of Northumbria is a
line of denial
No matter who it is
, the new story of Lavi, a girl who inherits the blood of a hero who will definitely protect her,
begins now
[music]